joe biden did a commemorative event for
five hundred thousand american lives
lost to cover nineteen obviously that is
a
massive tragedy every one of those lives
lost is indeed
a tragedy and the the goal here was
really
twofold one was for him to demonstrate
empathy as you will see this is the the
biden line right this is the line all
throughout the campaign is that donald
trump had no empathy but joe biden is a
man of empathy and this is what the
media like about him
is that he is capable of emoting i mean
that that is his right
it's his thing now i'm not saying it's
not genuine sure
i'll give him that i'm sure that a lot
of his his emotion is genuine
that's fine emotion doesn't happen to
solve problems very often emotion gets
in the way of solving problems and i
don't judge presidents on how much
empathy they have i judge presidents on
how well they do in doing the things
they are supposed to do
i don't care whether my plumber has
empathy i don't care whether my lawyer
has empathy and i don't care whether the
president has empathy
i am very i've been clear about this
since the get-go in fact there are good
studies to show
that sympathy is useful in politics
because it allows you to think about a
wide variety of people who are not you
but empathy is actually a problem
empathy is where you put yourself in
somebody else's shoes
sympathy is where you sympathize with
somebody else's positions empathy
makes you elevate certain people above
other people because you are empathizing
with them right so empathy can actually
be a problem in politics there's a great
book called against empathy
by uh by a psychologist all about this
about how it infuses how in politics
it's kind of a problem
in any case joe biden does this
event and in the middle of the event he
basically is the goal of the event is
not only to to demonstrate empathy but
then
to suggest that people who disagree with
his agenda
that the people who don't agree with the
way he's approaching policy are not
empathetic
right that is what politics usually is
is trying to create
a level of moral superiority for
yourself and make your opponents seem
morally inferior so
joe biden does this event and he says
for example it's time to end the
politics and the misinformation
okay as we've been talking about for
weeks at this point joe biden has been a
chief purveyor of coven misinformation
since his uh accession to the office of
president
he has put out the idea that there was
no covet plan a lie he suggested that
the covet vaccine plan did not exist
a lie he has had people promoting the
idea that teachers cannot go back to
school safely right now
a lie the president of the united states
has been
overtly using teachers union talking
points and just shoving them into cdc
standards
okay which is disinformation and
misinformation as the left likes to say
okay but here is joe biden nonetheless
saying that his opponents are the ones
who are promoting
politics and misinformation he's the
president he doesn't get to do this
routine anymore
now is the time for you to actually do
your job we must end the politics and
misinformations divided families
communities in the country has cost too
many lives already
it's not democrats republicans who are
dying from the virus
it's our fellow americans it's our
neighbors our friends
our mothers our fathers our sons our
daughters
husbands wives
we have to fight this together as one
people
as the united states of america okay
that is such a string of platitudes what
does that mean
what does that mean can we get specific
here
if if people are saying that you should
go out and you should congregate with
other people and there's no risk of
covet if you
without vaccination or anything and then
you should not wear a mask and not
socially distance
yeah that's going to spread the virus
okay so if you say that then that would
be and and you say it's not gonna spread
the virus that's misinformation
but if we are talking generally as joe
biden says that that
misinformation is the cause of the virus
spreading uh i noticed something which
is that andrew cuomo your favorite
government litera
governor literally lied to the american
people to his own constituents to the
families of people who died he lied to
his fellow democratic legislators and
your administration won't even say that
and then you have the temerity to get up
at one of these events and say something
like
we have to stop the misinformation in
the politics i don't believe you
i don't believe that you are interested
in that president biden i wish that i
believed you
but i don't but again the goal here is
just to get the media to to
cry over him which he uh which he did
successfully he was cnn's john king
saying you know he's empathetic that's
really the thing that matters is the
empathy the empathy the empathy you know
what i notice is actually more important
than the empathy reopening the schools
and getting people the vaccines they
need
and also not telling people that the
vaccine is not going to going to allow
us to get back to regular life
you want to talk about putting out
misinformation how about the idea that
we that we believe that you're gonna
transmit the virus at the same rates
whether or not you get the vaccine
okay that suggestion has been put out
there it is absolutely evidence-free
that's misinformation the vaccine does
lower not only a risk of death
to something like 99 your risk of death
goes down
your risk of serious illness goes down
by like 95 but also your risk of
transmission goes down by something like
according to the latest studies it's
misinformation to suggest otherwise
but we don't care about that all we care
about is that joe biden is a caring
person he cares about you
okay here's the thing let me just tell
you a little secret
joe biden may be a caring person the
government doesn't care about you
because the government doesn't know your
name
you're a taxpayer that's all the
government care that's all the
government cares about
you're just a you are just a tool for
them you're a widget to the government
now phil gramm the former senator from
texas he uh he was once
told in a hearing by by some witness
that that that witness cared about his
children and phil graham said really
what are their names
that is that is exactly how you should
respond when someone from the government
says i care about you your first
response should be
no you you really don't you care about
me in the same way that a plumber cares
about me paying him to fix my toilet
why should we pretend that our
politicians are the most caring and
wonderful of people when we all know
that this is precisely the opposite
but again you have to promulgate the
notion that joe biden is full of empathy
so that you don't catch on to the fact
that he's actually full of
here's here's john king from cnn
you have a president who is shaped joe
biden whether you're a democrat or
republican or independent out there
watching
he's been shaped by the personal tragedy
in his own life he understands what it
is like
for a family to suffer for a family to
lose and for a family to have to get up
and recover and that's why this is his
mo and his dna uh wolf to be an
empathetic president
and to not try to hide from these
numbers uh he inherited a mess in the
trump administration but he is now
accountable
in what ways he's been held accountable
by you in the media seriously have you
seen one headline holding to abide in
accountable for the hundred thousand
americans who have died since he took
office
and they every every day there was a
headline like it's unthinkable how many
americans
it's 83 vietnam wars that have happened
under donald trump
a hundred thousand americans have died
since joe biden took office i haven't
seen one of those headlines not one
but you know he's empathetic that's all
that matters dana bash did the same
thing on cnn you know trump was a very
non-empathetic character but
we know that joe biden is empathetic
he's all empathy all the time
what an event that uh the white house
put on
for the american people and for the
world to memorialize the half a million
people
who have been taken by this virus and
you know i don't want to do a lot of
looking back but at
almost the same location where his
predecessor
came back from the hospital having the
virus himself and ripped off his mask
what a difference just a few months
makes and having somebody who
as my colleagues have said uh you know
wants to emote and to empathize and to
sympathize
and to grieve with this country okay i'm
not looking for a psychologist i'm not
looking for a priest
i'm not looking for a rabbi i'm looking
for a guy who's actually going to do
what he promised and crush the fighters
he's not doing any of that stuff
in fact he's enthralled to a bunch of
people whose policies are completely
non-empathetic
because they don't actually care about
americans let me give you an example
rokhana is a democratic congress person
and he says he was asked about minimum
wage right the minimum wage is in the
joe biden covered relief bill
here's his response about minimum wage
killing small businesses does this sound
empathic to you because when it comes to
the policy this crap ain't empathetic
here is ro khanna how does this in your
view affect
mom and pop businesses who are just
struggling to keep their doors open keep
workers on the payroll right now
well they shouldn't be doing it by
paying people low wages we don't want
low wage businesses i think most
successful small businesses can pay
a fair wage so i love small businesses
i'm all
for it but i don't want small businesses
that are underpaying
employees it's fair for people to be
making
what they're producing and i think 15 is
very reasonable in this sounds
empathetic
he knows how your business runs better
than you do and if you don't agree with
him he's perfectly happy for your
business to go under
that's all that matters to him right
town is empathetic to you doesn't it
super empathy empathy he's empathetic
he's empathetic also if your business
goes under he doesn't care
also if your kid can't go back to school
he didn't care you want to know what the
actual
underlying emotivism here is about it is
all about
garnering sympathy for political
positions that are completely
non-empathetic
we all know this the biden
administration is mirroring all of the
priorities
of the american federation of teachers
when it comes to reopening schools
here by the way is what the american
federation of teachers president randy
weingarten had to say
about whether kids are going to recover
from missing an entire year of school
not being with their classmates
experiencing significant
mental health disorders really i know
many people who have had
kids who are suffering with this sort of
stuff here is the very empathetic randy
weingarten on this topic
i believe that kids are resilient oh and
kids will recover
oh but we as adults have to meet their
needs
their emotional needs their social needs
their learning needs
and that's who america's educators are
but at the end of the day
we have to believe that this is
recoverable
and we have to believe that virtually
all our kids
will thrive with the opportunities that
we put before them okay so what she just
said is f the kids
okay let me translate that very quickly
she said after kids that's what that
meant
okay so for all of the empathy and the
emotivism what it really comes down to
when it comes down to policy it's which
constituency can i please today
recognize this is true for all of your
politicians
democrat republican all of them anybody
who looks
for you you want sympathy get a dog
you want you want empathy get married
you want to
you want your politicians to bring you
these things you're looking for love in
all the wrong places and you deserve to
have
whatever ridiculous policy they promote
shove down your face
because if that's where if that's where
you're looking for your love my goodness
get a life get a community get friends
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional leftist
tier don't ask me why that's called
science to take advantage of this
amazing opportunity
hit the like button